French fries are delicious french fries
with ketchup are a little slice of
heaven the problem is it's basically
impossible to pour exactly the right
amount we're so used to pouring ketchup
that we don't realize how weird its
behavior is imagine a ketchup bottle
filled with a straight-up solid like
steel no amount of shaking would ever
get the steel out now imagine that same
bottle full of a liquid like water and
pour like a dream ketchup though can't
seem to make up its mind is it a solid
or a liquid the answer is it depends the
world's most common fluids like water
oils and alcohols respond to force
linearly if you push on them twice as
hard they move twice as fast
Sir Isaac Newton of Apple Fame first
proposed this relationship and so those
fluids are called Newtonian fluids
ketchup though is part of a merry band
of linear rule breakers called
non-newtonian fluids mayonnaise
toothpaste blood paint peanut butter and
lots of other fluids respond to force
nonlinearly that is their apparent
thickness changes depending on how hard
you push or how long or how fast and
ketchup is actually non-newtonian in two
different ways way number one the harder
you push the thinner ketchup seems to
get below a certain pushing force
ketchup basically behaves like a solid
but once you pass that breaking point it
switches gears and becomes a thousand
times thinner than it was before sound
familiar right way number two if you
push with a force below the threshold
force eventually the ketchup will start
to flow in this case time not force is
the key to releasing ketchup from its
glassy prison all right so why does
ketchup act all weird well it's made
from Tomatoes pulverized smash thrashed
utterly destroyed Tomatoes see these
tiny particles this is what remains of
tomato cells after they go through the
ketchup treatment and the liquid around
those particles that's mostly water and
some vinegar sugar and spices
when ketchup is just sitting around the
tomato particles are evenly and randomly
distributed now let's say you apply a
weak force very quickly the particles
bump into each other but can't get out
of each other's way so they can't
doesn't flow now let's say you apply a
strong force very quickly that extra
force is enough to squish the tomato
particles so maybe instead of little
spheres they get smushed into little
ellipses and boom now you have enough
space for one group of particles to get
past others and the ketchup flows now
let's say you apply a very weak force
but for a very long time turns out we're
not exactly sure what happens in this
scenario one possibility is that the
tomato particles near the walls of the
container slowly get bumped towards the
middle leaving the soup they were
dissolved in which remember is basically
water near the edges that water serves
as a lubricant between the glass bottle
and the center plug of ketchup and so
the ketchup flows another possibility is
that the particles slowly rearrange
themselves into lots of small groups
which then flow past each other
scientists who study fluid flows are
still actively researching how ketchup
and its merry friends work
ketchup basically gets thinner the
harder you push but other substances
like Oobleck or some natural peanut
butters actually get thicker the harder
you push others can climb up rotating
rods or continue to pour themselves out
of a beaker once you get them started
from a physics perspective though
ketchup is one of the more complicated
mixtures out there and as if that
weren't enough the balance of
ingredients in the presence of natural
thickeners like xanthan gum which is
also found in many fruit drinks and
milkshakes can mean that two different
ketchups behave completely differently
but most will show two telltale
properties sudden thinning at a
threshold force and more gradual
thinning after a small force is applied
for a long time and that means you could
get ketchup out of the bottle in two
ways either give it a series of long
slow languid shakes making sure you
don't ever stop applying force or you
could hit the bottle once very very hard
what the real pros do is keep the lid on
give the bottle a few short sharp shakes
to wake up all those tomato particles
and then take the lid off and do a nice
controlled pour on to their heavenly
fries
you